hey what's up everybody welcome back
welcome back to Lobby gang spot weekly
every Tuesday at 2 p.m. Pacific right
here on gamespot.com the electronic
triple is over gentlemen we survived
it's done in dustice Live still mostly
live yeah but we got a fun show today we
got some uh we got Aaron Samson here
Battlefield expert I know I'm inching to
get forward here I know Battlefield hold
your hores cuz I got to tell the folks
what else we got to play today we're
going to play some FIFA uh 14 the uh
World Cup pack has come out H for the
next gen version so we're going to get
Marco Martinez and Eric Taylor on to do
USA versus Germany see how that works
works out and in an also similar Forward
Thinking future sports situation we're
going to have Jeff grman fight Anderson
to Spider Silva and also uh have Bruce
Lee fight Chuck Morris copyright in the
UFC EA Sports ofk as it were something
wrong with your eye Danny yeah all right
nope we could make Mario but nend usual
Nintendo would want a profit share of
our stream Chris Waters hey buddy how
did you enjoy E3 uh it's a it's a
freaking blast man I even got to play
two video games what which is up from
zero video games last year what were the
two video games I played video ball live
on stage uh and then I got to play
evolve oh wow oh yeah I was very happy I
played the Kraken which is the new
monster I destroyed everyone the kraak
and also the the monster whose arms go
yeah I went summoned lightning bolts
down to destroy mine enemies yeah and it
was glorious Aaron did you play any
games at E3 I was playing some
Battlefield Hardline nice
um and mostly just running around taking
appointments yeah but I I'm cutting some
evolved today so I'm pretty happy about
that I'm rocking my brains I think maybe
I didn't play anything this year not one
thing I played one game the first year
and two games last year and I think
maybe I went the entire Expo whatever
you
might video game ah it's true the best
E3 experience although being there is
great the best E3 experience is actually
watching it on
gamespot.com nailed it all right Aaron
Samson we didn't bring your beautiful
face on this couch just to talk about E3
uh Battlefield Hardline uh so this is
this was announced well it was it was
announced about a month before E3 sort
of leaked little little leaky on Battle
Log yeah for sure uh you are you you
were one of the experts on Battlefield
you're probably the person who plays
Battlefield more than anyone in the
office in your home time I feel uh right
at the gate what are your impressions of
Hardline so visceral made or is making
Battlefield Hardline instead of of dice
this year they sort of handed it off VL
made I believe it was endgame uh DLC for
Battlefield 3 oh right did they okay
yeah they did that was just recently
announced these guys are taking their
best crack at their sort of crime drama
Battlefield game it's really interesting
like I'm having a good time I enjoy
heist mode a lot um I'm also enjoying
Blood Money it does so the the qu the
big question right now is how does this
game feel to players yeah so right now I
think viscol has a bit of an uphill
battle because it feels like a mod or it
feels like a piece of DLC I agree and so
they're really going to have to bring a
lot more to the table to to just
convince Battlefield players that
they're not just playing $60 just paying
$60 for you know a slightly iterative
experience I guess that's where maybe
the single player stuff comes into the
fold but the beta is out right now uh I
want you to jump in right now we're
we're going to ask you a bunch of
questions and if Folks at home have any
uh questions at all for Aon and and
Chris as well uh feel free to uh send
them and use the the usual we've
actually got the new Gamespot chat up uh
which we had over uh E3 any folks who've
been familiar with for/ chat on Giant
Bomb will know how it works so if you
have any questions do Daniel DWI or that
or feel free to H just stick them at
Gamespot on Twitter or in the twitch
chat and uh the folks in the back will
will'll get them to me here H first of
all white iron setting up Chris Waters
have you played much of this yet I've
played a bit Yeah I played a bit on uh
PC and on PlayStation 4 of course they
announced thing during the end of the EA
press conference kicking it off and well
all having to like wait a week to play
it oh yeah of course uh the beta is out
on PC Xbox One on
PS4 uh probably I'm not sure uh but yeah
so I've gotten bit of time with it on
different consoles definitely you know
Aaron Aaron sort of cuts of the quick
there with the is does it feel like a
mod does it feel and I mean certainly in
the beta form it's of course going to
because it's only a small multiplayer
bit there's only two modes one map um
and it's you know it it feels feels like
some it's running on Frostbite 3 it's
your the animations all that stuff is
very Battlefield yeah like the UI is is
basically what Battlefield looks like
like colors of the teams and stuff yeah
but you can sort of get this glimpse of
how they're trying to differentiate
within the uh Loadout screens within the
progression screens they're definitely
trying to create a different visual look
uh in those areas for it nicely done
that is some pretty great defense you'll
Park the uh car on top of the helicopter
before it can take off move that's
pretty good H for before people ask um
uh aon's playing this on PC and getting
moed and doing the uh so he's he's got a
self revive okay as part of his kit
which is really interesting and I really
I remember this having this ability in
Kill Zone 2 multiplayer and even though
it's something that like a lot of people
can use in this game you're just like
hardwired to think dead is dead
multiplayer shooter so so many times you
use the self-revive and just get up and
no one's looking at you
you could just could just murder
everybody other times you blow up but
you know whatever Aon first of all I
when to ask you uh the vehicles in this
game uh they feel a lot difference to
what the vehicles are used for at least
in Battlefield what's your take on them
in Battlefield 4 anytime you had a
vehicle that was a non-armored vehicle
like an mrap if you like hit a pebble
the thing would just explode I mean they
were really really underpowered so I
think visceral has done a good job in
this game of making cars more useful and
the purpose of that is you can get into
things like car chases you know cars
handle better they take more damage um
they can bounce off objects sometimes a
little comically like in the case of the
motorcycle you ride that thing along
walls yeah yeah you like hit a JW it'll
and it what's interesting is it doesn't
just like fly up next to the wall it
kind of looks like the tires like adhere
to the wall a little bit like cuz it
tilts a little it's definitely a matrix
style like wall it's great but you know
again I'm okay with these things as long
as there's purpose behind them and again
the purpose is to keep players in in the
battle longer you know you don't want to
just be riding down the street in a
vehicle and get hit by three bullets
your vehicle explodes and then there's
no car chases because vehicles are too
fragile so you know visceral said that
was one of the ways they differentiated
this game that's true whether you know
they need to talk about more things now
though like they need to talk about they
brought they brought some gadgets that
are new semi- new like the zipline sort
of a throwback to Battlefield 2 forces
are people using those so the zip lines
actually really cool to get from rooftop
to Rooftop is that mostly for snipers or
yeah well other players can use it for
example when you have get money and
blood money you run down the middle of
the street you're just going to get run
over by somebody so you can use a zip
line to you know bridge the gap between
two areas or get down the street a lot
faster now the grappling hook hold on
before we move on from zipline I just
want to confess I was playing a match
before we came on the show yeah straight
up shot to death by a zipline oh wait he
got shot the zip I got a dude killed me
with a zipline go we were in this like
he's on top of the garage I'm kind of
here I'm like my my weapon wasn't too
long range so he lined it up and then
all of a sudden just die that's like
getting killed by a smoke grenade and
Counterstrike this cable is coming out
of my killcam brain and it says killed
by zipline that takes a lot of talent
too cuz the zip lines don't just go
anywhere uh they only attach to certain
objects well it's sweet rocket launcher
what do you doing why you shooting that
thing uh that Evolution baby so you you
probably if you're on the team that's
cracking do want to take this crane down
cuz it blocks vehicle traffic okay um
that the team that's trying to prevent
you from doing that uh you know they
need to use those
routes this is heist mode in which it's
actually lopsided goals uh so it's more
akin to rush as opposed to blood Money
mode which is just everyone grabbing
money from the Vault and each other's uh
vaults yeah yeah what do you think about
the modes Aron obviously like you play a
lot of Battlefield you think this that's
the sort of thing that they need to do
to re-engage people or to make it
interesting if they're going to try and
annualize this thing I mean I would like
to see them come up with some completely
unique modes um blood money is pretty
good because it's this case
of focus um blood money is a it's a case
of a mode where you you do have some new
Dynamics like everybody's raiding the
center money pile but then everybody's
also going around raiding each other's
money piles yeah so that does feel
genuinely new heist mode feels like a
game of Rush obliteration it's not it's
not super unique but it is still fun as
long as both teams know what they're
doing yeah that's the one thing I found
that maybe on the PS4 there's much less
of is that the PC folks seem to kind of
be working together a little bit
better you think that's just sort of
down to the sort of the player base yeah
I guess I would make that generalization
about most uh competitive Shooters I
think if you want a PC that has that can
run this game pretty well then you're
probably into your first person shoot a
lot I'm going to dive into the user
questions a bit also want to let people
know that we are giving away 20 beta
codes for Battlefield Hardline on the
PS4 today woo the Gamespot account H has
just tweeted something I believe in the
past couple of minutes so if you want to
win H one of those beta codes all you
have to do is retweet that and make sure
you're following Gamespot so we can get
your details and get that code over to
you as well this is North America only
uh apologies that's uh that's not up to
us we got 20 codes so if you want to get
in on that retweet that by Boy hop on
him fast too I think the bait only has
two more days oh yeah you're right inste
be done yeah get the code watch the
starter guide that Aron and I put
together oh
run sweet it's like bike parkour if I
done that in Battlefield 4 I would have
died horribly uh final Dasa asks in the
chat do you do the classes represent the
cops versus Robert's Motif or are there
uh Thief engineers and police assault
how is that stuff working they're just
renamed Battlefield
cles are the same uh regardless of what
faction you play
as uh and they all at least in the beta
at this point the thing that
differentiates them I mean you have the
sort of the gun ranges right the SMGs
the machine guns the assault rifles the
sniper rifles like generally speaking uh
then you've got the bits of kit that you
can get so like the ballistic you've got
a riot shield in one class you've got
the revive teammates and revive your s
in another class uh Aaron you have done
some messing around with the riot shield
not not not useful yet it needs to stop
more bullets before it use it but one
one thing so one big addition that
Hardline does which I I think is worth
mentioning is it more or less gets rid
of that kind of slog of an unlock tree
that was in Battlefield yes um so it's
got the I don't we're just calling it
the coin op system um but it's basically
you pay money for the weapons instead of
having to unlock them through levels
although you still you do still have to
go through service stars in order to get
the ability to buy certain attachments
like Barrel mods and and Scopes and
things like that but for the most part
you're kind of able to just pick and
choose what you want right instead of
you've just unlocked this new version of
this pistol you never used anyway yeah
so veteran Battlefield players know
exactly which guns and you know which
Scopes they like and there's no reason
for them to be wasting their time
unlocking the Red Dot site for the 100th
time in a row it's just not necessary
and I think they listened and that was
that was really you know was really nice
of them to do I think it's something
that the community
wanted yeah you're not spending your
time with some gun you don't want kiding
it out only to unlock the basic version
of another gun that you then have to kid
out then you know to sort of cascade
along that's always it's nice to see
that getting restructured were you any
you guys talking to the chops of Vis cuz
I know that that there there's been a
low to talk about it's not all just
going to be maps in cities like they
definitely showed um desert maps in the
trailer desert cops desert bank
robberies that was where you had the
like real vehicle heavy during that
during the demo trailer that was where
it showed a lot of like vehicle heavy
car chasing stuff basically through like
uh you know Trevor and GTA meth country
is what it seemed like right uh so if
you're going to have a vehicle based
mode you know keep having it in an urban
area it's pretty tricky yeah so do you
think that the these these vehicles then
do have the ability to actually make
interesting uh vehicle chases because
one of the things AR and you said
immediately when that first trailer was
uh released was that if they use the
Battlefield 4 style Vehicles like all
that ever happened was people got rocket
launchers and just blew them up straight
away like there was not much in the way
of compelling chases yeah I think you
got to you got to recalibrate right
because the you know the majority of the
the vehicles in a Mainline battle field
are military spec they're tanks there's
armored this there's armored that but
here you know when you have you can't
you can have an armored SUV yes on the
criminal side but it's mostly going to
be you know cars that you can just
Commander like you know you sort of have
to rescale the damage modeling for
vehicles and it seems like Aaron
mentioned earlier that they've kind of
done that a little bit at least in the
beta though they are going to have to
drive car chases a little bit more so
again going back to heist mode it's
really good when everybody knows what
they're supposed to do and where they're
supposed to go um but in earlier matches
when people don't really know that uh
you know the team that they grabs the
bomb and they know where they're headed
they just go there and nobody can really
catch up to them so they probably need
to work Heist a little bit better so
that I don't know whether that means
just more cars or whether that means
more indicators do you think it's a
matter of confusion or just not being
able to get there in a timely fashion or
it could be you know it could be like in
Rush where they move the spawn point of
the Defenders after the first set of
crates are taken oh oh yeah yeah yeah
they should definitely something to
signal that yeah they need to rebalance
it a little bit just to you know
encourage those car chases so it looks
like my team's gone up they've gone up
and they're going to try and zip line
across to the Escape so we'll you're on
your own bro we'll go meet them over
there um but the potential for the car
Jes is there they just need to oh this
is
not the maybe maybe maybe slow your boys
down like it get back into the combat
area Aon you you play a lot of
battlefields uh there's no doubt that
you're going to pick this up on guessing
as somebody who who spends a lot of time
with the series H for folks who are
maybe fair weather Battlefield fans who
pick one up or maybe have been trying to
get into it so far from the beta do you
think that there's enough happening here
to make it an interesting New Prospect
for somebody who maybe played a bit of
Battlefield 4 but was a little
unsatisfied by it I mean if you're
looking for a different experience
that's what this is uh if you feel like
the battlefield franchise the core
Battlefield franchise has just gotten a
little tired then and you know I I think
you could make the argument that playing
it a slightly simplified you know
differently themed Battlefield might be
the thing that you want to do does this
feel simplify to you it does which is a
good thing I think Battlefield 4 sort of
branched out a little bit too much you
know there were so many weapons and so
many mods that it kind of got
overwhelming for a lot of players where
does that guy get shot
from this is this is one thing I like
whenever you're carrying money it's just
stream out of the bag leaving this crazy
money Trail oh make it make it that's
your friend it's F get out my way you
can do it
yes and Aaron wins the
game nice work Aaron one last I feel to
your question Danny about like Is this
different enough yeah feel like if you
want something different and the
criminal thing appeals to you Payday 2
you think like I it's very different and
the the mechanics of that in terms of
you know cuz you're fighting enemy AI
not not other players it can feel a
little
bit like horde mody where you're just
like fighting waves and waves of cops
but I think the strategy of pulling off
a crime and that kind of tension is
captured really well in Payday 2 despite
some some you know like rough edges
Payday 2 coming out on on the next gen
consoles or current gen consoles rather
in a couple of months as well I mean in
Payday 2 was done by an X Battlefield
Dev so if it feels you know mildly
familiar I mean the mechanics are very
different it's more like a hoard mode
that game is a lot of fun though the the
big the real question that everybody's
asking themselves at this point is is
this worth $60 yeah that's that's the
actual question you know if this were
$40 maybe there would be no question in
people's minds even if it felt like a
mod or felt like DLC so you know the the
VIS it's up to visceral to make the case
that this is a $60 game and that's hard
to do when you've only shown one map in
two modes yeah so we'll see what they do
do you think they'll lean on the single
player stuff though do you think they'll
say this is the single player campaign
you guys wanted and here's the the
multiplayer stuff to the side like
that's what I worry is that they'll
they'll have a pretty padded obvious
multiplayer component and then they'll
say oh but we gave you this five hour
campaign that no one's going to play or
like half the people are going to play
we had an interesting conversation in
the office earlier today where you know
somebody mentioned that the thing that
used to make make a game not a modern
not DLC was a single player campaign but
I don't feel like Battlefield people
play Battlefield for a single player you
know maybe it's 8 hours out of your 100
200 hours that you play so I think that
you know marketing thinks that single
player is the thing that attracts people
I think Battlefield players just want
solid multiplayer that's where they want
the money put and you know that's what
the experience that they want cool Aaron
thank you so much for coming on before
you go I've got the first eight winners
out of our 20 winners for the
Battlefield Hardline PS4 beta codes read
them out there bro it's most fun most
fun part of the show oh good yeah right
ER 10413 great keep going first one two
at
micf 18 you're just spelling them you
got to read them all right well how are
they knocking all right fine three at
hot Tracer 88 four at Chris scream five
at darkov I think that was Chris cream
but okay Chris cream keep going darkov
at the great
polio seven b boy Mr Maestro great love
that guy eight at still chewy chewy
thank you for still being chewy we still
got 12 more codes for Playstation 4 wait
wait show you the donuts oh get the
donuts go back to the game go back to
the game hang on just got to leave you
with one more thing this an Easter egg
that we were laughing at at the office
the other day donut Spott donut spotted
donut spotted [__] that donut looks
amazing God damn I love donuts [__] that
donut looks
amazing donuts confirmed follow Feld
Hardline thanks very much iron Samson
we'll be back in a sec with Ryan Mack
and Jeff Gman uh with UFC also Chuck
Maris and Bruce Lee if none of that
makes any sense make sure you stick
around uh but right now I believe a
Transformers movie came out which means
the uh Activision have uh squeezed out
some sort of software in relation to it
so let's check get the trailer for that
piece of hot trash probably
right when the universe presents you
with an
opportunity
you must never fail to capitalize
on this is our darkest hour the Autobots
are on the verge of
defeat a new golden age is upon us
Optimus the age of the
Decepticon ofs we must prevent the
Decepticons from getting the dark
spot
you know
you you want to go back
back to the heart of the
war Transformers the something of
something something out now from
Activision games by that if you like the
movie and want to see more of the rich
fiction of the Transformers Universe is
it right that I'm that apathetic about
Transformers the all spark Powers all
Transformers and Mark Wahlberg is there
it's going to be a fantastic time at the
movies be Brady can
you Jeff G from giant bom good to be
here light heavyweight champion of UFC
thank you very much for coming along
Ryan ma what's up thank you very much
for coming along Chris I already shck
your hand hey's what's up I'm just I'm
just going to sit over here the Ultimate
Fighting Championship finally has a
video game another video game uh I was
kind of hopeful about this one yeah I
played some last night it's kind of okay
maybe it's not as good as I was hoping
the more I played of it the less I liked
it really yeah oh that's annoying yeah
it's made from the guys made Fight Night
Champion which is a really really good
boxing game yeah but not a very good
mixed martial arts game as it turned out
so you know having those guys make this
maybe kind of a weird move especially
when EA made an MMA game out of like I
think tibron made that one and that had
some really ambitious weird interesting
ideas live remember that live commentary
they would invite people to like and
they would have like the devs or whoever
they could get to like talk over of
course you knew it wasn't going to last
was joean or Goldberg no no but it was
one of those things where like you know
with them not having the LIC it seemed
like maybe that forced them to try some
things they wouldn't have tried normally
and then you look at UFC and it's kind
of verif it Bears out where you're like
oh now they have the license they're
just like here's a career mode that is
like totally slapped together yeah I'm
not I'm not mad on the career mode you
know the ground game's kind of weak and
yeah yeah let's hop right into it I want
to I want to I I made a character
yesterday um this Chuck moris I couldn't
make Chuck Norris because why not
because they wouldn't let you have the
the surname because Bruce Buffer here
has to say somebody's name oh so just
Norris wasn't in the list it wasn't it
wasn't like specifically blocking Chuck
Norris okay all right H but just spelled
it with a zero and it would have been
fine for those who don't know the famous
fight between Chuck Norris I'm not sure
if we can ca to Enter the Dragon this
this Chuck Morris does not look like
Chuck Norris can we see the real Chuck
Norris so we can see that's as close as
I
got we're hearing enter to Dragon music
hear I mean I guess like you know like
he's not wearing the ghee yeah you
should have just named him CT I had I
had white shorts that's as close as I
can get they don't have white geese
pants no they didn't I put them on BJJ
shorts or something I don't know yeah
it's pretty restrictive which is a pain
because the Fight Night Champion stuff
allowed you to like share Fighters and
stuff but apparently they were really
scared about copyright infringement this
time around because you could just
straight up have Rocky and Gollum and
Gandy right sure you know I I bet
they're not necessarily scared of the
copyright stuff I bet they just didn't
build it because it's the first game and
they need something for next year or
didn't have time to do it until next
year cuz like this game just feels
stripped down Bare Bones the career mode
just there not a lot to it except for
like these 8sec video clips of Dana
White going good fight you did it good
going uh that are just super lame also
if you try and share those on the
PlayStation 4 it straight up just cuts
those every video is well apparently
when you stream it it even like cuts the
commentary the music what yeah the
background music cuz I had Lincoln Park
playing for Chuck marus you know
obviously of course American hero yeah I
know how you love Lincoln Park you got
to have the rights for that yeah it just
won't let you I that's super weird
though I do like that they animated
Bruce Buffer holding the microphone
under the dude's arms yeah they got the
referees in here I missed the original
Dude like that's when I think about UFC
I think about John was it Big John
whatever the [__] his last name was M
MTH yeah like he is the UFC ref of
record even if he has not worked for
them for years all right so who is Chuck
Mars uh that'd be Jeff Jeff no I oh I
might not be playing then okay are you
playing I thought I was playing I mean
we can do change Sid you can set this
up select sides is
confirmed there you go so now you're
Chuck Mars yes and Jeff is brce Le we're
not going to get trophies though okay oh
God damn it there goes half our viewing
audience they're just in for the trophy
side control look at this just want to
get up all Bruce if if you if it's Enter
the Dragon all you have to do is Bruce
Lee is just grab a clump of Chuck Mars's
chest hair whatever I'm going to break
his damn neck and then and then the cat
will look at you the cat one of the
things I found playing this last night
is that punches don't really feel like
they're that that strong uh you know I
feel like they're yeah I mean they're
that staggered him there Chuck Morris
you it's a forward it's like L2 and
forward yeah it's like
the Le is trying to get it on the on
the
out I'm just going to hang out here and
kick that was that was that was the that
was not the main event you needed to be
like water I need to be like I couldn't
do it yeah Chuck Morris is more like
wood we watch the the sick uh replay
here so this is as close as you can get
to the creating him cuz the the hair
that's yeah okay it's really there's no
sliders I think if you want if like if
you want this fight in a video game
though you got to go play Street Fighter
Alpha that Chun Le stage that is
basically the the stage from Return of
the Dragon like that's that's just a
much better a much better feeling
representation speaking of Good Feeling
representations you had great success oh
I I don't know if I would call it great
success but yeah sure great your Dude
Looks yeah I I waited through the Arcane
process of uploading my face to EA yeah
um now they have that now they have that
they had it before you know like let's
be honest they think I like hockey um
and or they used to uh and uh uploaded a
front picture a side picture and you
know it's all on the website now it
wasn't in the game uh which is weird can
you not just use like the connect or Ps
think that would be like a good way to
do it but I don't think so like the the
crazy thing is when you go to create a
fighter it actually just says like do
you want to use game face without
telling you what that even means or
where to go to get it or what you know
so you know it's it's a process I'd
install a browser plugin and do all this
stuff so I ended up uploading my face
and getting it all to spit out finally
uh and it created nightmares well let's
go check out those nightmares was it
like a webcam like that you I just I
just used my iPhone and took pictures
that way and they just want you to
upload jpeg I feel like in the past it's
been really finicky about where the
Shadows are on your face and it'll like
get real crazy about what a human's face
dimensions are yeah it can be bad with
that stuff they they draw a template on
the screen to for you to kind of drag
around put your eyeballs directly here
so that's I'm probably logged into that
just uh Brad uh it's not going to work
yeah you're going to get that so just go
to new user and play his guest all right
well whatever all right Patrick now G
get Patrick's going to get his UFC
achievements now instead yeah uh we just
should be hit rematch work who are you
playing who are you fighting I think
it's Anderson Silva versus Jeff gersman
oh great yeah all you have to do is make
sure you check all of his kicks and
he'll just break his own leg Yeah done
here's the spider he's pretty happy so I
guess the hardest thing when you're ever
when you're creating a character is
choosing what entrance music yeah and I
feel like all the options are poor uh
it's DMX but it's a really shitty DMX
yeah it's not the DMX song you want you
know they got that Imagine Dragon song
in there if you want like a really weak
fighter just like come out to this
Dumbass Song
um you know they got some some work to
do on the soundrack side let's say this
kind of feels like the we are going to
get it right Second Time Around totally
for the amount of time that this game
has been shown and not playable and all
other stuff like that they've been
working on it I'm kind of surprised that
it is as Bare Bones as whatever they
shoot all those videos and stuff that's
right all yeah 8 seconds with Dana White
going like great job kid you you SE
fighter remember what I said I wouldn't
work with EA well here we are you're the
new hoist Gracie H it looks like
presentation wise it's it's pretty
smashing but yeah totally I think there
there's some animation issues that they
run into with you know just certain
kicks clashing and stuff like that but
for me it's you know like the animation
looks good it's a good- looking game but
like the Jabs don't snap out the way you
want them to like the the input doesn't
it's not very responsive yeah and and
that's uh that's one of my main problems
with the game play uh for all the
problems I have with you know the kind
of the ground game and some the other
stuff they've done like like that's the
thing at the core it just doesn't feel
responsive enough well that's the
problem that they ran into the first
time cuz right remember it was it's
always the animation versus respons so
they do they do that swimming thing is
like where you kind of swim through what
you're doing to match up with what's
happening right so it's like yeah I gu
but you know it's like I I feel like you
know the the EA MMA game was was pretty
awesome uh well it it was pretty all
right they did their own thing that was
different from thq's UFC game but I
think I you know like playing this I
would rather just play thp game like by
the time they got into their third game
what does Bruce Buffer call you when you
when you come in uh Black Mamba great
but uh but this PS4 is not set to stereo
output so we're not going to hear some
of the channels oh
great even weirder you're looking pretty
cut yeah you know this is what I would
look like a 205 it's pretty it's kind of
terrifying cut weight down to 205 you
know not eat for a while uh I didn't
make light heavyweight because I thought
I could fight at
205 uh it was more that I think that's
the division where the action is so
that's usually the you know that's it's
kind of annoying that you can't fight
outside your weight like you can't like
drop into just yeah just like like just
fudge it like make it work like even in
Champion they let you go I believe one
above and one under like if you wanted
to well so in in online they kind of
combine uh middle weight and light
heavyweight okay uh and and you know
some of the other divisions they do
combine some of their weight classes so
uh that does happen here and there and
if you want to buy Bruce Lee well I
think if you complete the game or career
mode the hardest setting or something
you unlock Bruce Lee and it's like seven
bucks I think to buy in all the weight
classes and otherwise not even all of
them cuz it's like three of them like he
doesn't he does not there's no
heavyweight Bruce Lee oh yeah yeah uh
you know like there's four different
versions though two books each yeah it's
that stuff's ends up I think that
stuff's lame cuz you end up in the
character select screen and online
matches and stuff and you'll see two
versions of the same guy back to back
but the character select screen is
already just this tedious thing in this
game that should have been streamlined
and and to loading in general is fun
Tokyo tires is your I just randomly
chose some sponsors I don't even
remember I had alien wear and everything
that's smart straight up alien know you
can put an Alienware logo right on your
junk as well I put the tops
logo cuz I figured they would send me
free baseball cards that brand is hot I
Happ all right let's do this
boys who's who Anderson SP I hope you're
Jeff Gman cuz otherwise he's going to
get super ran are you swap swap Sid swap
you want swap Sid all switch anyways
switch sides you what I'm saying I don't
think I'm oh you don't think you're in
yeah yeah oh you're not all right okay
that right yes that's right all right so
fighting as Jeff Gman is Jeff Gman and
fighting as Anderson Spider Silva Ry
McDonald's the match you've been waiting
to see for a shot at weidman's title
well yeah getting in his introductory
hugs yeah hold you Mac going straight
for the flying
knee as is want of Silva oh
Jesus Jeff if you were saying we're not
getting all the audio channels
necessarily is like impact one of those
audio channels uh it could be I don't
know is a weird mythical machine and
there are weird menus you have to lie to
if you want to get two channel audio out
of it uh for you know capturing on a
video game website or something like
that
there's have you seen any low blow stuff
happen in this yet m I don't think any
that's in there the cage uh no I've seen
the refs like stand people up in some
cases where it's you know it's like the
the action's kind of stopped can you get
in there and give him the old
Suarez just little little shoulder bite
just a little bit of yeah little bit
little bit gum on shoulder look at
that oh well there you go here now we're
making babies some of the welts and like
swelling and bleeding and stuff is
really well done like you can really see
like thighs
getting getting nice and pink from a lot
of work getting done to them the way you
like it
getting bruised up I I get
it oh my almost the spider's down gave
him his chin he got up pretty quickly
that's the problem with silver now he's
been knocked out
once that's what happened to me I was 14
and three when I was
playing got knocked out Dana White says
all right kid you can be back and then
drop the next two fights and then they
just stopped they sto calling you they
stopped calling the phone stopped
ringing and I didn't know what happened
man training camp was
empty everyone said there was some new
guy on the
scene they have caught I always said
it's my big fist I'm ready to fight and
they just weren't listening that was
definitely a little blow they have Irish
MMA practitioner Conor McGregor in here
but right after they scann him he got
this massive front tattoo on his chest
which is just not in the
game all the better for EA trying to
work out that legal stuff I did I did
see some Mario's face tattoo on his
chest well they're getting into a lot of
heat
with really yeah like getting the rights
from Individual artists who made the
tattoos and stuff and you end up with
some cases where people get you know
licensed things tattooed like CM Punk
has a Pepsi logo tattooed on himself
that was always real hard oh oh Anderson
Silva don't let it
be 20 5 seconds can he
survive I take questions from the chat
but unfortunately my laptop has died so
oh so and so is Anderson silv Anderson
Silva so yeah at no point was there any
sort of like head size slider after I
like once you import your game face it's
like all right you're good you can't
really change the hair or anything in
game oh really uh like all that stuff I
think happens on the website you can't
do the tweaking uh no no there there was
limited tweaks that I could make and
most of them were to the body I was
going say this is a pretty diminutive
head as a representation of you yeah no
I I know I want to get it get it looking
much bigger but the headbutts oh gosh I
I want Mark trell style all the time
well you just want to even make just
dumb characters like I tried to make a
really dumb character yesterday and sure
he had blue dreadlocks and a red beard
that was their size but like that's as
far as I could go it seems like the if
you the the key to making really dumb
characters in this game would be to like
go to the website and upload like a
picture of a basketball and say that's
your face uh and see what Happ happens
or just take a screenshot of your UK's
WWE character and so yeah that was the
idea is like what happens if we took a
picture of this character and then
re-uploaded it over and over again
machine what would what would eventually
become um well that's that's EA Sports
UFC yeah out now folks uh before you
guys go I want to ask you a little bit
of questions about this Steam Sale
that's happening um I'm buying a load
this year because I didn't actually buy
that many in previous years uh whenever
it was on my PC was always in a limbo
where I was moving or something uh have
you picked Chris have you picked up much
this time around uh no Danny I not
although I did see Brothers on sale for
like three bucks or something like that
and that's one of my favorite games of
the last year so I'll plug that sweet
sure all right we got to look at what's
on there what we got spin Blacklist
ghosts 60% off and Murdered Soul Suspect
like cut by about
33% came out like two weeks ago yeah it
came out the before E3 right yes it did
yeah it did yeah so that that's a that's
a decent price for that game that game
is has some interesting ideas that I
would not recommend as a full price
product but you know you cut it down
enough it's like H you know you you
could do worse $679 for Fallout yeah
it's been it's been out a while the
Metro pack is pretty good uh all the
expansions are in that as well I yeah
but then there's that new Metro pack
like the the remasters are coming out
like not that far off so this is like
their last ditch like hey come on man
buy Metro at n hog for what is that six
59 pay any price for n hog as far as I'm
concerned as long as you got people
around that's Dark Siders too that's
been that's been a while can you click
on the blue team thing this is the most
like just rigged thing I've ever seen in
my life like is somebody just miles
ahead again come on Team Pink yeah it's
what Reddit is gaming it to have every
team win two twice twice over the course
is that what's happening wow that's
pretty all being yes back at it's all
fixed it's like life let's go all right
let's vote on the next Community Choice
then Eric T cams what we
want Samurai gun that wasn't one of them
you get to vote for oh you have to pick
from these you pick from these two I
would go uh I would go fun great
soundtrack over casual comedy that's
what I would pick yeah let's give our
boy cassavan a bit of a bump there as
well yeah clearly clearly they need it
no one no one's heard of this Bastion
game transist thing died on its feet I'm
sure what is that all right Steve sales
go waste your money now well don't stick
around we still got a we still got a
show to put on here in fact I believe uh
Mary Kish is here with there's not just
steam sales there's also actual boxed
retail releases coming out this week and
Mary Kish is on on our green set to tell
us all about them Mary what's going
on no Mary's not there apparently don't
worry there's no such thing as retail
box games anymore really it was all the
r we're done digital only y I still
can't pay $60 for a digital game it
feels very strange not even when they
pack in some extra for you or something
if you could what if you could preload
it then it feels extra new so so I will
say that say what you will about the
game but I will say my most successful
digital pre-order thing ever was Watch
Dogs so I did I could have went at
midnight to Best Buy but instead I said
you know what I'm okay with Watch Dogs
if it takes a little time for to get
here but seriously 12:00 came and it was
like I hit the button and it was like
yeah but then 12:01 came and you were
playing Watch Dogs well then then 1212
came and I caught up to where it
downloaded to and this big fat thing
came on the screen I was like oh sorry
you need to sit here for the next 7
hours pretty much it's good thing we got
you on that first 12 minutes yeah UFC
lets you go through the tutorial uh it
downloads two gigs and it's like you can
totally play I'm like oh fantastic get
in there walk through the tutorial which
I had already played uh and get in like
that first fight and it's like down you
want to play that again and then you do
career mode and it's just the tutorial
again right they're just like kick punch
kick punch all right I got a quick
question actually uh speaking on the
subject of like betas and stuff that
came out during E3 we were talking about
Hardline earlier Destiny Alpha was also
there for a little while did any of you
guys get to play around that I ended up
playing it before the show we ended up
getting a hold of it uh before the show
but by the time I got back in range of a
PlayStation 4 it was already closed yeah
but I I really liked what I saw of it
yeah that was you know that was beta of
the show between that and
Hardline uh Destiny or Alpha Beta of the
show uh Destiny is definitely the did
you because it sort of gave you a few
levels you know you could level up to
like eight or something like that it
didn't take very long to get through
yeah yeah uh but then they also had the
compe a competitive multiplayer mode
there which I only dabbled in a little
bit and we had on the stage show but it
was it was basically like a domination
game type one part of the game I didn't
see because there was no one playing it
when I was playing it so are they going
to do that beta again you think it goes
into beta next
month so this is the AL Alphas betas
digital games time we talk about some
retailed box games Mary Kish what's
going on oh hey
guys you're not married at all good not
this is the Rouge oh did I get you
Handler you did it again oh that is
good well look at here Human Being Mary
Kish is on vacation sorry everyone but
I'll take over for here now look at this
what do you have there what what you
been what do you guys think I know not
to good but uh Tuesday on it's looking
pretty hot is it what's I think so
what's what's on Tuesday well let's take
a look on what's on Tuesday J Christ we
got well actually that's later but but
right now it's Sniper Elite that's going
to be on Friday guys that's not Tuesday
Mary no Mary's blowing it isn't she but
no it it's looking real good you got uh
you know adjust your speed and hold your
breath as you take these shots but most
importantly you get my favorite crack
chat here comes oh no not that is it
going for
the those do not grow back guys never
had they been more lovingly rendered oh
that's fun and that's going to come out
again Friday June 27th is going to get
mided that sucks he'll be okay I got to
oh playing that game that stuff gets
gruesome this one is on the 24th it's
Transformers rise of the Dark Spark
count wave oh it's good for campaign
mode you can play either as the Autobots
or the
Decepticons where you get to either save
or destroy the Earth do you to quote
carollyn pet it if you can transform
it's not going to be the worst
Transformers game ever exactly this one
uh takes on the more different approach
of War it's World War I that was a good
time for everybody I feel like
Transformers is the more different of
those two types of War but okay very
much so but this one brings in a love
story about survival sacrifice and
friendship guys wow this Trifecta right
there it is if I think franchise I think
World War I okay this is a shovel KN
where you use a shovel to oh we just
went right past that but you use it to
uh dig up stuff and uh it sharpens so
you can kill people as well up next is
uh Auto Sport Grid Auto Sport the
27th and that's going to be for
Wednesday you put these in order next
time Mary I could but it's not as
fun wow I'll be here next time probably
not what's your what's your favorite
game coming out this week Rob oh
probably some Sniper Elite yeah some uh
C ATS those look insanely awesome you
like shooting Nazi dudes in the balls I
do I do that's what you do the weekend
Rob Handler I got to say h that Grand
Theft Auto video you put up last week
was something special H we're going to
run it at the end of the show as well
congratulations on making content that
is better in video form than what
Rockstar are doing in video game form
you're too kind Danny thank nice work
all right Rob pleasure take off this
yeah he's gone can you come back in that
was great oh he's back hey Rob on your
head on your head Rob here we go duck
duck duck here go on you can do it keep
it up what on
do and the Like
Beckham come here hug me hug me hug oh
no hug me y there we go oh look at that
no Danny makes it weird he's always got
to take giving you a tongue bath it's uh
actually a feline form of
affection weird thanks
Rob oh my God that was weird it was
pretty weird and we're going to play
some FIFA 14 a second Germany versus the
United States of America but first uh
next big game is on this week uh tell
the folks at home what that's all about
I don't uh so like next big game right
is this feature where Gamespot just kind
of like highlights a game that's super
awesome and uh the people who make it
sort of like the website equivalent of a
a magazine cover story where you get to
like delve into the game and like really
sort of take a look at what makes a tick
uh which is really fun extra fun when
it's evolved and you get to go play
evolve so there are four videos going up
this week and pieces alongside them oh
oh oh 10 four five they're five days in
the week five five every they're actual
seven days in the week but okay damn it
technicality uh so yeah so there are
five classes you can play and evolve the
four hunters and the monster so uh We've
posted medic and assault assault went up
today and then we've got Trapper and
support tomorrow Thursday and then
Friday the monster so yeah Peter Brown
did some interviews with the developers
at Turtle Rock about the uh different
character classes I sort of delve down
onto the one specific character and
talked about their strategies and the
videos and uh put together a little
video feature here for you guys to like
get a taste for what it's all about EXC
all that's on gamespot.com but yeah
first of all here's a little sneak peek
at the next big game
evolve this week evolve joins Titanfall
and civilization beyond Earth on the
list of elite games to be featured in
gam spots the next big game series and
what pre tell does that mean the next
big game not only focuses on games that
will have a big impact on the industry
it also highlights the developers that
bring these experiences to life so all
this week on Gamespot you'll find
interviews with the team at Turtle rock
studios and video features that give you
a glimpse of what it's like to play each
class of Hunter not to mention the
monster if you don't know why evolve is
our next big game then you haven't been
paying attention it's a 4 on-one
multiplayer battle as four players try
to combine their class class specific
abilities to take down the fifth player
who is a giant freaking monster Godzilla
is a lot scarier when you know there's a
human intelligence behind it and
wreaking havoc as an eldrich God is so
much more satisfying when you know
you're terrorizing your friends this is
the kind of game in which no match plays
out the same way and every match is a
story so take some time this week to
check out our next big game coverage of
evolve and see what we're all excited
about please get me out of this
Plant World Cup 2014 is in effect it's
happening oh it's so I don't watch
soccer until the World Cup comes around
and then I watch a lot well you got a
good dose of soccer this time around or
football UK and Ireland Europe what's up
other places in the world except for
America sure we used to call it soccer
in Ireland I don't know why people are
it used to be okay in England until like
the ' 80s as well people got
oversensitive about it was it was
basically when American football started
getting broadcast in the UK that people
started to get funny about football
soccer thing no no no this is our
football it was fine Ireland has gay
football so we're used to having two
sports anyway we you call it soccer
anyway regardless USA are playing
Germany in a big old game H thanks to uh
Bradley's little mess up uh some bad
defending and Cristiano Ronaldo
realizing that he was Cristiano Ronaldo
in the last hey maybe I should show up
uh 95 minutes 94 minutes late to the
game but uh I'm here guys what's up I'm
spoiling the us at automatically
advancing so Thursday morning it's all
on the line against Germany yikes so
what better way to figure out who's
going to win that game than by having
Eric Taylor and Marco Martinez step into
the shoes of USA and Germany H you guys
should probably swap sides Eric are you
playing as Germany I'm playing as the
United States he's playing as America
it's
fine just get on the next screen just
hit just oh he's got as Captain America
he's got Captain America on Marco you're
a traitor to to your Mexican side that
you favor yeah for the sake of this
we're just going to say he's supporting
Mexico only but I know he's got uh he's
got split allegiances he boys we're
going to talk to you at half time uh but
for the moment I want the two of you to
concentrate on your game uh and then
myself and Chris are going to do our
best uh Univision sln commentary uh over
this so best of luck and also if you
have any comments in the chat I got my
laptop back please send them over as
well great to see joy out there with his
bionic leg they recently put in using uh
Brazilian monkey fur oh got early chance
here for closa trying to become the uh
leading a score World Cup history exact
wow you you really know your uh your
knowledge used my two facts up and it's
all downhill from here Josie ala is
Bradley who had a bad game against G in
the first game and uh had a a good first
half against the Portuguese but uh
proved to a a little bit clumsy at the
end of that game o oel mop o off the end
and it's going to be as Tottenham fans
say his eyes are offside his eyes are
offside mirav Ozil his eyes are offside
I don't that's also that's not his first
name I don't even understand what that
means he's got big eyes oh Bradley over
the top servicio on
dsei o Safe Way cleared out Johnson
Jones Johnson working it outside the old
box situation and it's a sloppy pass
müller's going to take that one we got a
Germany on the Counterattack here oh
Closer Closer fighting for it and he's
he's going to beat the Gonzalez closer
than close is that Gonzalez yeah that's
not a very German name that's no that's
a different I he's a United States okay
okay he's a stater Johnson at the wing
to
Bradley oh looking for that across the
middle ball and it's just right there
for Kobe Jones to and Alexi lwas to
sweep up i' never heard of Alexi L moved
here oh really yeah also Steve McMahan
is a punded on ESPN how the [__] did
that happen I don't even know is that is
that he he related to Eric Wala sure oh
he's going to throw
trste the big save by Timmy Howard basan
Schweinsteiger messes up how can you not
say Schweinsteiger like three times it's
so fun
Schweinsteiger Kevin Prince that's not
Kevin Prince boang that's his brother
the one who didn't decide to play for G
Bobby
boang close again into traffic and right
boys this is a the look already talking
to each other getting a little bit nervy
here Eric Taylor's leaning in look at
this he's worried oo dead ball situation
Tim the beard Howard has it covered
though Tim the beard he's just like
Jersey beard face that's it apparently
he's also got
Tourette's I did hear I did read that
yeah there you go energetic fell which
helps when you're screaming at Defenders
all day actually it's probably pretty
good oh there was a hand ball surely on
that one but Ball's forward got
Advantage not going to call it dling
around in the box is that guy music dude
123 in twitch asks do to have figing
injuries in this game
fainting injuries they don't figting
injuries oh figting injuries
Unfortunately they don't they I don't
think they've ever had that in a game
they had intentional foul in I think it
was FIFA 98 um but uh I don't think
they've ever had dive fing injuries I
feel like you need you're getting into
this like mutant League mutant League
football territory of like bribe bre
like how do you it's like then a dice
roll to see if it works like you have to
build in some kind of chance system
Wonder red card had us red card was a
game where you basically got points for
getting people sent off as well oh here
we go
Jo this what happens when you've got two
number one commentators yeah I'll be the
color guy you'll be the color guy I'll
be the color commentator you'll be the
you'll be the pressuring the US easy to
move it around to the back pressing up
the middle now and uh they're looking
for a through ball to Dempsey Dempsey
I'm going to be the color commentator
also comes in with questions from the
chat yeah that works H also I want to
let the people know at home that uh this
is not the World Cup video game this is
the uh free moving in with that big
head you're really good at
this H this is the um free upgrade pack
for uh the next or current gen version
so this is for this is the PS4 we're
playing on uh so this and the Xbox One
version there's a free download Pack and
they have this friendly mode and there's
also Daily challenges based off what
happens in the uh in the games is this
the haha suckers who bought the World
Cup game mode we're giving you that
stuff basically for free FIFA is that
what I'm hearing there's definitely like
not as many modes in this as there would
be in the full R relies this is there
we're sorry we didn't get R into making
a nextg World Cup game oh okay oh surely
off sides there Josie alador taking
shots from outside the box like some
sort of desperate [__] come on Eric
Taylor you're better than
this wait who's which one's Eric
Taylor's the United States Eric Taylor
is United States part of America over
the top shipping it up for Dey
Dey shoots with his left he shoots with
his right d makes drba look shy
no or maybe you got all the chance down
man yeah he doesn't play for f anymore
though so I I can't really use that
anymore it's been a lot of possession by
the US and a lot of pressure up front
after a few quick counter strikes from
the uh German side us has been knocking
on the door de late in this first half
question from Chino who's going to win
the World Cup will two teams be in the
final sorry he said which two teams will
be in the final pretty sure two teams
will be in the final go ahead and say
Yes uh who do you think Chris o alidor
who do I think based on first round play
yeah I I don't Netherlands Brazil that
that is that does that seem pretty
pretty like some pretty strong teams I
think that can't happen I might not be
able to happen I think they will meet in
the quarterfinals they before that yeah
I don't have the full bracket in mind
but uh I don't know Germany some pretty
strong all right games as well Score
first half here you're a little yeah
let's let's uh let's talk to both
managers for a second uh can we talk
Eric Taylor are we on Marco Martinez I
think you guys are on uh let's have a
quick chat what's it feel like to be on
a live stream for a soccer video game
and be in a scoreless draw at
halftime go ahead it's a dream come true
it's a dream come true it's amazing I'm
going to win that's it you're going to
you're going to break American Hearts
yeah for no reason other than
Fame that's the kind of TAC turn
attitude that's given Martinez great
success as the German technical director
Taylor how did you get Alor back on the
pitch considering he pulled a hamstring
two weeks ago uh same reason
steroids I was about to include Landon
Donovan but but we we went against that
just because he's doing a great job in
those commercials so fair enough all
right back to the game boys back in the
second half what are the keys here Danny
for uh Germany if they want to punch it
in and avoid utter embarrassment on the
international scene by drawing or losing
to the US I think what uh Germany have
to do here of course Germany if they
draw this game I think our oh no both if
if a draw will put both these teams
through indeed there was talk of
collusion by many as uh Jurgen clintsman
and the technical director of the German
side way back and may or may not be
related by blood I guess we'll see if uh
if somebody scores uh late into the
second half then all gloves are off what
would definitely help is if both teams
went into Ultra attack right now Ultra
attack oh here he is Johnson pressing it
down the side waiting for his team to
catch up trying to get a better
advantageous shot in the middle and no
oh amazingly both America and Germany
have opted to go for Ultra attack wow
it's as if both are s sensing the
desperations in their squad and utterly
unaware of the realities of World Cup
qualification H does this game support
EA Game Face ask
oh he's got demp or Bradley in the
middle thanks for getting me a trophy
bro appreciate it that's what we're in
it for folks I'm not sure I think the
old versions have
gamey Bey you doing your Univision
commentary see Danny do your I don't
know any Spanish you do
it def
Al Alan
no oh poor ball wrong wrong option there
my
friend this is squeaky bum time 60
minutes to go you know what's really
going to help these teams here Danny is
uh taking that ball bringing it down the
field and just getting it by the keeper
for a goal is what they are really
trying to strive to do here I think you
know for the German team right now this
key in this end of the field yeah
prevent that ball from going in into the
goal past the keeper kill screen asks
what is the point of the map at the
bottom of the
screen uh it's like your radar it's good
for like doing like really ridiculous
like long balls oh God out in front of
the entire German Squad let's see if he
can finish
Legend it's going to be a
goal
that
they
Mira closer there achieving the highest
goal score in the World Cup the assist I
thought CL was on the assist there maybe
he was assist I don't know I wasn't
watching I'm the I'm the Cockney I'm the
Cockney uh uh color commentator who's
actually a bit wasted so I don't really
know what's going on I'm Vinnie Jones
it's Vinnie Jones here V Jon would be
really good at what these americ need to
do is [__] hit those Germans right
they got to hit them
Lord oh
penalty that's a penalty I don't know
who's a referee they've obviously paid
him off those stinking Germans like he's
oh he's off sides he's off sides oel
offside terrible Touch by the defender
Gonzalez but manages to get on top of it
closa trying to claim that Throne that
he's currently sharing with Ronaldo from
Brazil is it going to be an out side
shot terrible percentage here he's taken
to the Baseline try to cross the back in
front nope rob robed you can you can see
the uh the despair in uh the manager
there Eric Taylor's face you can't
believe this is
happening these Americans need to pull
the [__] finger out
right need to just get it
done this is war This Is War but it's
actually one of
football I don't know I've heard
say Safe Way great bit of clearance
there by Tim out jela ATO got to use his
bionic leg there get the ball up the
pitch oh hello oh my goodness terrible
defense for
alos Johnson
oh the
leg Jones oh
JJJ this Quicky bumped 7 minutes left in
the
game oh too close again Sebastian noer
there no problem for him he can catch
American balls all day
long ah desperation you see it's just
knocking on the door so hard but no
one's answering here we go Josie can he
get the ball in front
and missed it ooh
SE my God that's worse than Bradley's
against Portugal what we do with
Taylor a draw would have put both these
teams through Vinny Jones would have
scored that Josie Josie Josie C get
Josie
no put it in here we
go oh incredible amount of chances for
the American side there and they just
couldn't put it in one wonders if this
is the time when we really see one
minute injury time how far America's
come on the international scene how far
they still have yet to
go oh desperate long balls what is this
ball and that'll do it and ozil's broken
himself oh he's going to miss the finals
what's happened to him what's the injury
dislocated shoulder ouch
ouch yeah let's Sub in in uh stoppage
time well at least he still got a legs
to stand on
it it it automatically does that oh
really yeah when you get hurt oh
what and then it does that little thing
there we go that's it America is out
here it is my God Marco Martinez as an
American how does it feel like to put
out Beast medals how does it feel #
Beast medals to put out put out America
it was amazing uh I knew my team was
going to do that from the beginning I
was asked to put my hand behind my back
maybe to give him a a handicap but I
didn't I played 100% I Won Won nothing
let's see the stats real quick oh Eric T
wants to have a look at the stats is
this shot stats oh that's closer than I
thought what is that seven shots Seven
On Target that's pretty good it's
consistence German efficiency right
there accuracy rate absolutely 100% shot
accuracy good
game snubbing you just missed
the the sports blogs are going to be all
a twitter about that Marco Martinez uh
Eric Taylor thank you very much thanks
also for not biting each
other oh oh they almost went to kiss
each other there the bite kiss it's a
complicated expression of emotion I
don't know about you but I'm spending
9:00 on Thursday morning in Kate
O'Brien's to watch the watch the game
really you should come along I will go
to there we're going to go we're going
to go not go to our meetings and watch
watch sports and drink beer in the
morning it's the American way and thanks
everyone for watching Lobby today and
not the was it Greece
and uh it was Columbia Japan and Greece
and that's when we see the drop off
other team that's we see the drop twitch
numbers and gam spot numbers go thank
you very much for hanging out this week
in the lobby we'll be back next week as
ever thanks very much Jeff G Ry McDonald
everyone for coming on playing video
games with us of course Aaron Samson as
well Samson as well Samson we'll have
Delila on next week uh yes that's that's
oh yeah we know what to do one more
thing I forgot about uhoh we got we got
more giveway for Battlefield Hardline
you guys better download these like
immediately CU you got like 48 Hours
unless they extend it I think they are
there's only 10 there I think we need
two more you want to hear some winners
how about Amy Val Dave great name yeah
going home to do crimes JoJo 671 you
seem like a motorcycle driver to me Cody
unor C please just get out of the top of
that building stop trying to snipe get
into the action here Aion
xplays the Mac 53 379 stink fish and
that's how I say things when they don't
have vowels in them greo fail let's hope
you are better at crimes Than
groing Ready Steady Ruck soda pop 6580
48 48 just want to be want to be clear
that was a 48 and Batgirl
Chessie great sweet work y'all I hope
all of you people actually have
PlayStation 4 thanks for tweeting hope
you have the PlayStation 4 uh remember
do crimes or don't do crimes that is the
question and we still got two more to
give away so keep retweeting and make
sure you're following us uh that's the
gam spot account when day about I don't
know let's say about an hour ago uh we
still got a bunch of more codes to give
away so yeah keep retweeting or follow
us we can get make sure we DM you the
codes uh yeah and then we spam your
Twitter account for the next uh next
couple of months mercilessly yeah like
third party retweets to things that are
like Twitter with a few RS on the end of
all your information to our friends at
Ubisoft so they can make you play an
even better experience I got so pissed
off you play this morning still carrying
that aren't sorry I got to go I gotta go
we can't do replay I want also yeah okay
after the credits stick around we're
going to have Rob Handler's amazing
Grand Theft da Community video but
that's the lobby for this week so thanks
very much hanging out Chris Waters
thanks very much hang bro we see you
guys next week have a great week face
some video game Steam Sale money money
Mone
money
n